welcome everybody to the h3 podcast
i'm here today with youtuber contra
points aka natalie
thank you for joining us hi eva hi
everyone thank you so much for having me
on
we were talking we originally had you
scheduled to come on
the day after the election but there was
so much going on we decided to wait and
let the dust settle a little bit yeah i
would have been like
comatose i don't think i i don't think
it's such more than a couple hours that
night i was just like
glued to twitter for 16 straight hours
uh it would have been it would have been
bad i was the same way and i was uh
were you losing your mind a little bit
during that period and it wasn't 100
percent
yeah it wasn't fully and i was obsessed
with like twitter and the news and
it was just it was really oh yeah it was
a horrible week
terrible like like there was just like
90 consecutive hours of like pacing in a
bathrobe looking at twitter just like
really bad bad times i gotta say that
first night was
was pretty when i went to bed i was not
feeling very happy
i didn't go to bed i thought i had to go
to bed
because i have a kid so i was like well
yeah yeah i just got to take care of
this little guy
yeah that's good it's good to have um
something else in life to like be
responsible for
because well i started getting house
plants that's my
the level of responsibility i'm
comfortable with but um
yeah that's that's i know i was i was i
was
i was losing it i mean i at first i was
like having
i was definitely having flashbacks to
2016 when you know
everyone said i said hillary's gonna win
hillary's gonna win hillary's gonna win
and then that night
well at 9 p.m or whatever like trump
starts winning states and
it looked like that was going to happen
again this time even though we all
knew like everyone said like oh there's
gonna be a blue shift it's a red mirage
like don't
worry about it like he's gonna you know
but somehow like i just
i guess like four years of like
political doom for me has kind of um
trained me to expect the worst
well i was really hoping because you
know the polling was so
dramatic was like 10 points here
billion points there so when when
florida
fell to trump i was really hoping it
would be like a swift knockout with the
enormous lead he apparently had in the
polls
but trump like you know won florida big
time and then i was like okay well
it's gonna be a long night you know but
[ __ ]
well now that it's over how are you
feeling over quote unquote
um i'm feeling pretty good these days
like i guess
the first few weeks after well how many
weeks has it been it's been
one month i guess uh the first couple
weeks i was like
i don't think trump's gonna leave like i
think um i think he's gonna find some
way to i
i didn't you know i i mean i guess it
was paranoid a little bit but
i feel like it was paranoia like sort of
informed by well informed by the fact
that the president was like i'm not
leaving
but that makes you kind of like that's
not paranoia like that's just what's
happening
i guess the question is like does he
have the actual power to
to do what he obviously intends and
wants to do
um so i it appears that he does not
but for a while i was like i could
actually i can imagine a lot of
scenarios where like if enough
republicans kind of lined up behind him
and i don't know he was somehow able to
convince
uh like like send different electors to
the electoral college or something
really
obscure like that i don't it looks like
that's probably not gonna happen
but uh yeah i'm i'm calming down a bit
about it
yeah i'm i'm feeling the same way i'm
feeling like for sure he's gonna
leave but i'm more worried about like
the
he's just scorching earth you know what
i mean on the way out and it's like
people are it's just so [ __ ] up but
you know it's kind of ironic is
the republicans in georgia and this
runoff that's so important are now
losing faith
in the election process and i'm starting
to see a lot of them saying well i'm
just not going to vote
because my vote doesn't matter so if
that's
if that's the case then that would be
the most poetic justice possible for
his tantrum well it's also it's kind of
true that like
if you tell your base that the
election's rigged like
the votes are all lies like it's not
like necessarily the best get out the
vote messaging
you know like it's not good campaign
messaging
to say the election's fake it is good it
is good messaging to drum up violence
though expedition which i'm which scares
me a lot
yeah exactly i mean
it
i think um there's so many people in
this country who are kind of like close
to the edge
um you know especially if you look at
like q and on and like
i feel like a lot of people have been
further sort of sent to extreme places
by the pandemic the fact that
they are like sort of not socially
connected to other people
and the kind of conspiracy theorizing
has like no cis no checks on it at all
and then you have like the president
basically encouraging this
saying the elections stolen and saying
like you know we're gonna
we're gonna basically uh you know we're
gonna take victory by whatever means
necessary and he hasn't said that
in that those words but he's implied it
and like
who knows what trump means to say that
by that but i can imagine
you know several thousand people who are
gonna hear that
and think it's my patriotic duty to take
up
arms and like attack who knows what
an election center i don't know
government buildings like
uh i can it just seems highly likely
that
there's gonna be violence that will come
of this yeah i would agree
but if you're so you i mean it sounds
like you made a video saying you know
about voting
urging people on the left a lot of
people on the left were are disinf or
disenchanted let's say with like joe
biden because he's too moderate
well what's the point so you made a
video urging them that it's important to
vote for biden so
what can you outline to me like if trump
won
in a second term what is it about that
second term that would be so horrible to
for you well i think if he had a second
term
it would sort of embolden him to be sort
of even
more uh sort of
um embolden him to even further
disregard democratic norms to be as
you know even more authoritarian to be
even more outlandish on twitter
uh not i say outlandish as if that's
really the problem it's not just being
outlandish
it's being like you know just sort of
unhinged and cruel and
um you know it would potentially put him
in a place to to
choose yet another supreme court nominee
and i don't know
i just there's a lot of like very dark
implications that i see that that having
um so uh i also you know it would also
give him longer
i don't believe trump believes in
democracy i think he clearly does not
um i think that he i don't know
it would give him more time to basically
you know lay the groundwork for the
trump dynasty basically and i think that
would be really really horrible for
democracy in this country so uh of
course we'll never really know
um like the extent of the disaster that
we just averted
but i think that it's like
a huge step back from the edge of a
cliff basically um
i'm not super enthusiastic about joe
biden i don't really know anyone who is
to be honest
but i feel like at least this like hits
the pause button on the slide into hell
and like lets us kind of like regroup
and think about what to do next
well i saw this headline of like george
bush bill clinton
and obama all together pledging that
when the vaccine becomes available they
will all
take it publicly to boost confidence
like these are normal presidents like
you may not agree with them but they
definitely care about democracy in the
country
and yeah we can all find that common
ground at least
but i oh and like i i didn't even say
anything about coronavirus
like this this president who like
basically i mean he basically has
said that like wearing masks is for
sissies like i'm not doing that like
look at bojob and he looks like such a
[ __ ] with his giant you know you know
mask
like like like in the middle of this
pandemic that's like killing at this
point what is it like 3
000 people a day like it is just like
the worst
leadership you can imagine in this
situation
i believe he said two days before he got
coronavirus about look at joe bite he
wears the biggest mask i've ever seen
whatever that
mask yeah so now they say i'm immune
so um i love all the sworn affidavits
rudy's sworn affidavits there's some
great clips that just came out
i think this morning i saw them and you
know people
whenever i talk to people about like
who doubt the the finality of the
election
they always talk to all the evidence of
voter fraud and specifically the sworn
affidavits
so ian do me a favor and pull up this
clip here
this is this is one of the people who
testified with a sworn affidavit that
rudy giuliani brought into court to
testify
so we can finally get a peek in
like a lot of people think all indians
look alike i think all chinese look
alike
so how would you tell if some child
shows up
you can be anybody and you can vote and
if somebody with my name you can't even
tell my name
anybody can vote like
compelling stuff so the argument is that
votes could be fake because how can you
tell chinese people apart
is that the argument yeah ethnic groups
look all look the same
and she's like listen i don't blame you
because i think all chinese people look
the same it's just the way it is
it's fine to be it's fine to not be able
to tell people about i mean it's just
yeah
wow that is uh that sure is an argument
yeah
but what's great is that rudy giuliani
was like i'm bringing this woman to
court
she's compelling this is this is going
to convince them this is going to
convince a judge
right another one by the way he was
cracking up next to her i don't know
i don't know i don't know that that's
necessarily good
that the lawyer is his witness is that
what you want your witness to do is to
uh
entertain the courtroom like everyone
just
[ __ ] rolling on the floor i don't
know
yeah but what am i what are we supposed
to say like how do we have a
conversation with people this
to talk to the sworn affidavits but this
is the content of the sworn affidavit so
like
what how do we how do you communicate
to people that like are so fully
convinced that
the election was stolen which by the way
last i
checked which was you know a few weeks
ago to be fair but like
88 of republicans think that the
election
was rigged 88
yeah i mean i'm someone who
i think of myself as someone who's like
likes to try to communicate with people
i disagree with and i like to try to
reach out to people who
uh you know i think have a backwards
point of view and try to understand
where they're coming from
but honestly with people who support
trump in 2020
i've kind of gotten to a point where i
feel like
there's such a level of detachment from
reality that i just cannot
get through like because i don't think
that the issue i guess
is that when it comes to like election
fraud i don't think they care about
evidence like i don't think they really
care
um because if they did like
they would be looking for some you know
like like
and you know you can debunk each
new piece of evidence they bring forward
only for it to be replaced overnight
with a new thing and everyone forgets
that the old one is debunked so it's
like
it's like this impossible task like this
hydra that you're trying to kill of
misinformation right
where you said you know you
okay oh there's there's this video of
where it looks like you know and you
debunk the video and you said that takes
six hours of work on your part and then
everyone immediately forgets that that
was ever used as evidence that the
election that there's election fraud
because they move on to some new piece
of evidence so it's like
i don't know they believe it because
trump says it or they believe it because
believing it leads them to reach the
conclusions they want to reach
right which is that trump should stay
and we should find a way to keep them
right like it's not about what's true
it's about like
how can we build an argument for
the conclusion that trump should be
president despite losing an election
how do we bridge the gap like i mean how
do we
what's the remedy i mean it's just it's
i don't know
you know last year with obama
with hillary when hillary lost you know
there's there's always been
a friction and growing friction but now
it's like
like you said it's like different sets
of reality i mean how do you bridge that
i just don't
i don't see how to overcome this maybe
it's just something that over time kind
of goes away like
you know mccarthyism and there's there's
been errors in
in human history where [ __ ] just you
know kind of
disappears maybe when trump finally
leaves it all kind of just
fade away i do you think it will fade
away or is it something that's not going
to go away
i wish i thought it would fade away but
i don't um i'm i'm really worried about
this country to be honest like
i think um you know i think that things
have
always been you know it's easy to forget
that that there's always been these
tensions like i mean
this country had a civil war what a
hundred and
uh you know 50 some 70 i guess 179 years
ago
and um it's kind of
uh
it kind of never stopped you know like
that that some of these conflicts like
never really resolved like especially
conflicts about like what
is america's relationship with race for
example like that's kind of an open
question it's never really been resolved
and i think that um
you know the tensions kind of builds
these critical points and
it sometimes eases a little bit but it's
always there um but yeah i do worry that
it's it's gotten to such a point of
division that there's not
really much communication across the
aisle
and it's like it's it's kind of hard to
see a way out of this that doesn't
involve violence in some way
now i hope i because i really hate that
um
i don't know i'm i'm very averse to the
idea of violence i know like on
on political internet it's kind of
become like
fashionable lately to like fantasize
happily about like
the guillotine and revolutions and all
this and it's like
that's like such a bad thing to have to
do though it's what i feel like people
don't
realize like if you have like if you
have to solve political
crisis in your country with like of
civil war that's like the worst
possible thing that can happen it'll
ruin like
decades of all of our lives and a bunch
of people die like let's not do that
but i don't know to me i think it's
about
it's about like reaching out not to like
die hard trump supporters but like to
like
people who are kind of like not
necessarily because most people i don't
think are super involved in politics
and you can kind of like like trump is
doing things now that are very
very like outside all norms that we've
ever had for this country like
like he basically is like you know out
basically
has decided to reject you know the norms
that make
democracy possible so i think that you
can appeal to a lot of people by just
being like look like this is not how
things work in this country like
we have always you know this country was
founded by people who wanted to show
europe that a democracy could work or
public could work anyway
and like that means peace a full
transfer of power
and if you are out here saying like
oh we'll see if i leave if i lose the
election i don't know about that i'll
think about it you know what i mean
like that's a pretty dangerous attack on
like what is kind of the most
basic principle of you know
how this country is supposed to run not
by a dynastic
you know family not an arist not a king
not an aristocrat but like
by elections that's how we're supposed
to choose power and if you reject
elections and it's like
you're kind of rejecting like what is
the basis of america
and i feel like that is something that
most people in this country
will ultimately kind of they will reject
someone who
uh attacks democracy in that way but
there's plenty of people who won't and
it's also it's it's definitely a scary
situation
yeah i feel like he found a way around
it because he said he he's not he
convinced people he's not attacking
democracy he's just
he just got it was a fraud they they're
the ones attacking democracy
but that's kind of like the propagandist
playbook it's like you're not doing what
i'm doing
i'm not doing what i'm doing you're
doing what i'm doing but
and you have just yeah how do you fight
a civil war though like how is that even
logistically possible in the united
states now
like back then they had cannons and
muskets and [ __ ] and like everything was
kind of
drawn out in a way was like north for
south there was some kind of
definable line but like how was a civil
war even possibly be found in the united
states without like
total annihilation and like whoever's
the sitting president the party
how can anybody reasonably rise up like
a bunch of dudes like with
with some you know our home arsenals is
not
there's not going to be you know what i
mean like versus the government
it's it really just depends who's who's
currently
the president i think if it came to that
level of violence
yeah it's hard for me to say and again
like you would really have to kind of
ask someone who's like an expert on the
military
all i can give you are my like dark
twisted fantasies
like i don't know i guess i imagine like
like the nightmare scenario is you've
got like
cavalcades of like trump suvs like
roaring up i-95 waving guns and then
just like
i don't know antifa like roadside bombs
going off and like
like i don't know right why is that so
easy to imagine like
i i guess at some point obviously like
the military would be called in there'd
be tanks on the highways and like
uh i don't know so so it's a kind of
question of like where is the military's
loyalty gonna lie
um i actually think that especially with
biden having one
i don't think the military will defend a
trump coup attempt
like even if he is clean you think they
would before i wasn't i didn't really
think before
i don't think so either um it was more a
question of like oh is he going to be
able to do it without like violence you
know
the question is like oh is he going to
be able to persuade enough people
to go along with this like the election
as a fraud line
um that he's able to kind of like
overturn the results of the election
that's more what i was worried about
um but i can't imagine i don't know like
without having like total war like i can
still imagine a period of like
frequent like skirmishes we could say
yeah like we kind of had all year
honestly like with
with the clashes between protesters and
riot police
just with guns this time yeah with guns
i mean
there's already kind of guns there's
kyle ridden house there's uh
you know people driving cars and vans
into
crowds there's the police firing you
know
tear gas at pro like it's it's escalated
pretty far already
what is the deal with this kyle
rettenhauer what am i missing about this
dude
he drove from out of state
he murdered two protesters and now the m
my pillow guys is bailing him out
literally my pillow guys put up two
million dollars bail for him
but what i'm missing what how is this
not clearly murder
well it is clearly murder but i think
people like i think the people who
support him think that it's like
justified murder
because they see it as like i mean and
again it sort of tracks some of trump's
rhetoric right like
if these democratic mayors won't keep
their cities until
under control then like we're gonna send
in the the military
and do it and i think the people who
admire kyle rittenhouse they think of
him as this like
hero of like law and order who's like
there to suppress the like
unruly protests right because their
whole this whole law and order line has
been about
like oh the real problem with this
country is these
these crazy leftist rioters these
looters these you know
we need we need to basically
dominate them right that's what trump
trump was saying he was
he was doing like a palpatine tweets you
know just tweeting like
domination and power in all caps it was
like coconuts so it was
back in july like i was like this feels
like you're so powerful
yeah not good and like and
i guess he was yeah he was giving off
palpatine vibes for sure
yeah especially with all the steroids
first yeah and i think that people see
rittenhouse as like
you know the vigilante version of this
it's kind of weird but it's like so
nonsensical right because in the one
hand you're saying oh law and order law
and order that's what we care about is
law and order
but on the other hand you're saying oh
it's great that vigilantes with guns are
breaking the law by shooting people
right if it's in the service of what
their idea of law and order is
right which is i mean like it's like
what martin luther
king said about like uh you know peace
without justice like that's
that's what they want they want uh they
don't want justice they want
a peace that's founded on people simply
like keeping quiet
do you what do you think the left is
doing wrong because like
you have what essentially is a bunch of
rural working class people who are very
who are probably
for the most part very poor who are
coming out in droves to support a guy
who's
has a apartment on the first floor of a
manhattan penthouse
that's literally plated in gold and
probably shits
in a gold toilet so how the [ __ ] is this
guy able to become
the working class hero and the left is
unable to get any of these people's
votes like what what
what what is the left feeling so
desperately at
well i have a couple of thoughts about
that one of them is that i think that
a lot of trump's like a lot of you know
for instance the counter protesters with
guns that we're talking about
these people are not the like poor
working class like
weapons are expensive like you don't
form a militia like on a on a but you
know apparently rittenhouse used his
stimulus check
to buy the weapon so this was the
socialized weapons presence
yeah yeah
well yeah i think that um yeah that's a
real puzzle though isn't it though like
why do like
white people who are not like upper
class at all
why do they see this like
vegas like-esque like walking like
gold toilet of a man like why do they
see him as like some kind of work
he doesn't care about that he doesn't
know anything about them he wouldn't
hang out with them
you know it's like the dude spends all
of his time on these ultra luxury golf
golf courses like the dude wouldn't
[ __ ] ever golf with you he doesn't
care about you he never wants to hang
out with you
he [ __ ] never he's never known
anybody like you like he's literally a
big town
ultra rich dude like right the heights
of like new york elitist
like rich father like yeah well i think
i think that these
i think these people know that like i
think they're not dumb like they know
that
trump doesn't represent them and that
trump doesn't really that that
that trump on some level doesn't really
care about them but i
i think that for some of them anyway
what it seems to be is it's
it's almost like trolling they like
trump because he pisses off the like
the big media liberal types who who
don't represent them
and he pisses off what they see as the
the establishment right
i think that's true of some people on
twitter right but like yeah i'm talking
about like
rural people that don't
use twitter they just like if you drive
through
if you drive through you know
cross country all these states in the in
the middle that are read is just
trump trump trump signs magga everywhere
these people don't go on twitter like
but they but they love
trump and it's not about trump they're
not trying to make libs cry they just
love trump
well i think um
i think there is like still even with
like the west you know pennsylvania type
people like there is
still this sense i mean this is like an
old kind of a historic resentment in the
us like along the east coast i know like
the western part of all these states the
carolinas virginia
um pennsylvania like
there's this like long-standing
resentment of the east right all these
states have capitals along the east
and the east is seen as cosmopolitan as
urban as elitist and as kind of
almost like an oppressor right of their
way of life it doesn't represent them
and so i think uh
i think it's kind of an enemy of my
enemy situation where they know that
trump isn't one of them
but they do like even if you're not on
twitter like
trump pisses off the people on cnn for
example and they like that
right they kind of like that he's like a
middle finger to like political
correctness
and to um this is how they see it of
course right is he actually uh
you know i don't know but i feel like
that's
just it's so obvious because like the
democratic
platform is a platform that would
directly help them
the republican platform is a platform
that directly helps
wealthier people so it's like
everybody's voting against their own
interests
somehow yeah well i think um
i think it's like a very dark mindset
that leads
to these people to vote for trump like i
think on some level they're not
expecting things to get better they and
and
it's almost a kind of nihilism that's
set in it's like well you know
at least we're gonna like you know let's
just burn it down almost i think
some people have that kind of attitude
where um you know
i think they think oh maybe the
democrats will will help them with like
health care and things but they know the
democrats aren't going to bring back
like coal jobs or manufacturing jobs
and there's this sense i guess of like
loss of like pride and loss of dignity
loss of and loss of like
obviously like financial stan standing
as well um
not wanting just like what they see as
like sympathy handouts um you know
socialism
but wanting like i don't know this like
america first rhetoric i guess appeals
to them
people want to feel like the winner
people want to
you know that i guess people a lot of
these people will attribute like
sending jobs to china for instance for
like taking away
the industries that used to thrive where
they live i mean and to some extent
that's true but a lot of it's also
automation so it's
you know it's not just that and but i
think that's you know trump's you know
china
rhetoric kind of connects about that
with in that way but
you know you'd think four years later
when manufacturing has not in fact
returned and
like you would think that they would
start to get disillusioned with trump
so i don't know it is kind of uh
uh i mean someone really should do i'm
sure people there's people who do this i
should seek this out people who do like
interviews
go across the country and ask trump
supporters like what are you doing
yeah i mean they're well ask all guests
no bricks is kind of
doing a pretty good job of that he's the
one who told me like dude he told me
before
the election like trump is definitely
gonna win because i travel all around
the country
and everybody's maggot out so he was
pretty confident that trump was gonna
win one
but but apparently he's got something
coming out that should be really good
that's pretty much exactly what you just
said
but i'm kind of i'm more curious i'm
very curious about the you as a person
if i can switch gears a little bit sure
um
where did you grow up where are you from
i grew up in a suburb of washington dc
northern virginia
oh washington dc is your is your family
in politics
no they're not um although many people
in dcr i knew like a lot when i was
growing up you know i knew a lot of
people who were like
like children of like lobbyists or the
nra for example which is in
northern virginia um did that form
you're like
being and do you think being around
politics like that formed your kind of
world view as an adult well it was i
think
probably to some extent like it was
definitely like very often discussed
growing up like it's something that's on
a lot of people's mind you know
i was in middle school when 9 11
happened and a lot of i just remember
the
other kids crying in school because
their parents worked at the pentagon and
they
just heard that flames flew into the
pentagon like so it it is kind of like
uh it is very much on people's minds
there um
but uh yeah i don't know to what extent
that like necessarily influenced
me now except that it it's made me sort
of i remember thinking about politics as
early as being a kid yeah
what do your parents do for a living or
or do they share your your politics as
well
uh well my my mom's a medical doctor
and my dad's a college professor and
they are they are both uh democrats
um i would say that i'm i don't know i
don't know actually i don't really
talk politics for them so i don't want
to speak for them but but
i i feel like i may be a little bit a
little bit to the left of them and the
way that like
you know it's it's most young people
have an obligation i think to be a
little more left to the
of their parents right but uh but um
yeah no it's not it's not like i was
raised in like
i don't come from a conservative family
your
your um your college days kind of
interest me because you were going for a
phd in philosophy right
yeah that's right and then you just you
bounced out
existential boredom i think you
described it as
yeah yeah i really could not stand
graduate school like
i i don't know i i liked um well i guess
when i was in high school i was i
almost failed out of high school i was
terrible student really um
yeah well i when i was in high school i
kind of all i cared about was music
like i played you know of several
instruments
and i just wanted to play music all the
time i was i had a hard adolescence i
was very angsty and like
i dealt with that by playing music so i
actually tried to drop out of high
school but
you know my my parents and the school
was kind of like
no you're not doing that but they kind
of like made a deal with me where they
let me take like
music classes in high school and and
and so i managed to get a high school
degree that way uh
i spent two years at a music college
berkeley college of music in boston as a
piano
student when i graduated high school
then i switched you know sorry go ahead
i didn't mean to interrupt you
no no like ask ask this question now
because i'm about to move on
well i'm just wondering what was so
tough about your high school that you
were you know about to drop
out of high school um i think
i was just i was just very depressed as
a teenager
yeah uh i was just having a hard time
with it and
i dealt with that by kind of retreating
into music i didn't want to think about
anything else i didn't want
i didn't want to take math classes i
just wasn't having it
were you like confused about your gender
identity back in high school was that
part of the depression or is it
something else
i think there's some of that i think
that i it's hard exactly just to say
how much is what in retrospect you know
what i mean like how much is this like
gender angst that everyone says gets
worse in adolescence
how much of it is um i don't know like
clinical like depression
which i was like treated for pretty
extensively at the time
um i yeah i had a lot of like
psychiatry growing up um you know my
parents being in uh my dad's a
psychology professor my mom's a doctor
so
there was a lot of a lot of a lot of uh
i mean i started taking adderall when i
was like eight years old
like like that kind of that kind of a
childhood you know
i see you know does having does having
doctors and
and psych your dad's a psychiatrist or a
or like a therapist he's an academic
he's an academic psychologist but like
but both my parents i think they kind of
felt like
a little bit qualified to like have like
mental health judgments about their kids
yeah what does that what do you think
about that growing up with parents who
feel like they they can have this kind
of
they they feel like they can you know
diagnose you
to some extent is that is that well that
was very much
my experience uh and some of the things
i think they got right some things i
think they got wrong
um like i was kind of well they got
right as the
like the depression stuff like that that
was real but i think i was like
misdiagnosed as like ocd
um well and if you go back and like look
at a lot of the things they were
complaining about they were
calling me ocd rituals they were like oh
because so
i was i was a boy at the time uh um just
in case
people didn't pick that up uh you know
at the time that this like i just be
like oh like he spends too long with his
hair like he spends too
long like there's too much grooming
there's too much concern for like all
this kind of stuff
and it's like i don't know with this i
feel like that would not be seen as a
psychiatric symptom
if i had been born a girl you know no
so i yeah yeah i feel like it was though
even even if you were a boy
it seems like a stretch it was it was
too much there was too much there was
it was a little bit too much psychiatry
going on for sure you know i
i have a member of my family who's
younger who has also
prescribed adderall at a young age like
similar years and i
always felt like i i personally was
never comfortable with it and
i saw how she behaved when she was on it
and always maybe
like i've taken adderall i mean it's not
it's by no means
of a negligible drug i mean you could
get
up on that drug i mean i take it now
sometimes but it's it's
it's it is speed like yeah no it keeps
you up it kind of [ __ ] you up you're
wired as [ __ ] like it's it's it's
more than coffee like it's uh oh it's
yeah it's like kind of wild to me that i
was taking this one as eight
so i yeah i mean looking back what's
your opinion on that because
like i said it's just i can't imagine to
me it seems like a hard drug
like it's not even a song yeah yeah well
i don't want to blame my parents too
much because i think that they like
their heart was in the right place they
thought they were doing the right thing
but i do think i was over diagnosed and
over
medicated as a kid and as a teenager
yes that's a tough situation you know
it's funny because you
you when you look at these kinds of
movies like garden garden state was it
yeah and his dad are i forget the exact
details but
there's kind of a trope about the parent
who's the
psychiatrist or therapist or whatever
always diagnosing their kids and giving
them drugs and
[ __ ] them up in that way yeah i think
that
the movies like that like tend to
probably go to a little too far in the
other direction as in terms of being
like
psychiatry is bad like throw your pills
away you don't need them like that
because
obviously that was kind of the stuff
wasn't that like the ending of garden
state or
garden state yeah like i feel like
that's like two that's taking things too
far
like because obviously like these drugs
i don't know it does help a lot of
people
but i do think that especially with kids
like it's a little bit wild i don't know
are kids supposed to like our children
like naturally
i don't know i feel like that
genetically we're not made to like sit
in a room
still for nine hours and not move and
not mess with our hair and not
you know what i mean like that's so
that's not a medical problem
that's just a kind of social expectation
that we thrust on eight-year-olds
that we then try to fix them with drugs
and it's like
i i totally agree i mean looking back i
don't know how i made it through those
years
like waking up at five in the morning
getting on a bus doing like these are
things today that i would
rather die than do on a regular basis
pretty much
oh yeah no i think like the amount of
hustle that takes to be a kid
to wake your ass up that early spend a
whole [ __ ] day sitting in a desk
come home do homework probably not
getting enough sleep too
you know it's it's it's brutal the
regimen
that they could take so yeah i think
like school used to say it was like 7
20. school starts at 7 20. like that's
when i was in high school like
it's so early yeah i think i can count
on one hand like the amount of times in
my adult life that i've gotten up for
something
at 7 20. like exactly
part of that said i've organized my life
so that i don't have to but
me too i feel like my whole my whole um
trajectory in into adulthood was the
simple
objective of never having to wake up to
an alarm clock
ever again yeah i definitely had that
like i used to have like nightmares that
i would end up with an office job i feel
like that motivated me in a lot of ways
like
to to you know i tried to try all this
stuff before finding something that
actually worked as an alternative to
that
but but yeah i just really didn't want
that for myself
and so i basically my 20s was a series
of attempts
to to not have to wake up before 10 a.m
so what other what other jobs did you
attempt
well i guess when i i mentioned going to
music school
um i dropped out after two years because
i like
at the time i just felt i came to feel
that i just didn't have what it takes to
be a professional musician
in retrospect i quit way too soon
because i think at the time i was
thinking like
i was like yeah i'm okay at piano but
there's like 14 year olds who are way
better than me so
[ __ ] it i'm out like but in retrospect i
was like 20 years old
like shut up baby is what i want to say
like looking back like you can do
like you from 20 you can do almost
anything with your life
um but i i was i don't know i also was
getting curious
about other things like at the time i
was starting to watch youtube
back then um and i watched like
all these like um like atheist youtubers
oh yeah i remember that well yeah i'm
sure i'm sure a lot of us remember
like i'm talking 2009 and um
there was a name for the click it was
like the uh
youtube atheist movement like youtube
skeptics skeptics yeah
skeptics yeah so i used to watch that
kind of content
and i guess honestly that played some
role in like getting me interested in
philosophy i was like oh like
uh you know i i i guess i got
sort of interested in that and i was
like oh maybe i should actually go to
maybe i should actually go
back to school and like go to like a
school and like you know learn about
that instead of doing this music thing
so i kind of went to community college
for a year
i uh i worked as an assistant in a
neuroscience lab
and i went to um then i transferred and
i
uh to georgetown where i got um
i got my undergraduate double major in
philosophy and psychology
i worked really hard at that because i
think i was trying to like compensate
for the fact that i was so bad at being
a student in high school
like i was like no i'm going to show
that like i
so i had like i graduated like
georgetown like like
i don't know 4.5 i'm sorry like 3.5 or
3.6 or something gp like
like i was getting like straight a's
some semesters i was i was such a little
try hard
um i think i felt like i had something
to prove
yeah so at what point
i know you like you transitioned
kind of or what age where you were a
little bit later
yeah like 20's or something i mean i
transitioned basically on youtube
like i started when i was 28. um
so i wanna um
i i personally don't i don't think i
know any trans people personally
so i want to ask you questions about
this but part of me is like
i'm afraid to talk to you about it in a
way because
i'm afraid of saying the wrong thing and
then getting cancelled on twitter
okay well i'm not gonna i won't i won't
cancel you i i won't cancel you on
twitter
but i'm being but i'm you're afraid that
other people will yeah yeah but
i'm you know i've i'll yeah
but you do know what i mean like i feel
like people maybe are afraid to even
talk about the issue because it's so
it's so sensitive and it's kind of like
a new issue socially too
if i can even say that well it's not a
new issue but it's
people's awareness of it on a large
scale is kind of new
yeah um i mean like there's i guess
there's been times in history when
people have become aware of it again
like
in the 50s there's a trans woman called
christine jorgensen who
i guess transitioned and and like had
all these surgeries and
i think denmark and like she was in all
like the american newspapers and like
it became sort of a famous thing but uh
yeah it's a kind of
i guess it's that it's definitely at a
new level like where it's
in terms of people's awareness of this
um and part of that's that traditionally
like what trans people do basically is
try not to be seen basically um there's
always this sense that like if you
actually want to transition and live a
life in a new gender
like you need to like you need to change
your name you need to move cities you
need to cut all
ties you need to not tell anyone that
you're transgender basically
um and i feel like what's happened in
the last couple decades
is is we've kind of decided that that's
actually a kind of like very repressed
existence and like we should be able to
be open about who we are and we should
be able to talk openly about these
experiences
so you have um you know a lot of more
trans people sort of who are willing to
do that
um which of course comes at a cost to us
because a lot of people
are not like very sympathetic to trans
people right
so if people know that you're trans like
they're going to be an [ __ ] about it
so that's you know that's
that's the trade-off you're being honest
but now you have you know
now you have to deal with the
consequences of that honesty yeah it
seems
it seems like a very shameful thing like
you described before like you have to
move to a new city and all this yeah and
um
does it do you feel did you feel when
you started to become
well let me step back like when did you
first start becoming like confused about
your gender let's say or i don't even
know confused is the right word
it's a difficult thing to describe i
mean i had um
i had feelings about sort of
gender i guess mismatch i guess we could
say sense like childhood
i guess it became more of a thing in
adolescence where
i i don't know i i so
i i mean i was i was attracted to women
when i was
um a boy but i guess which is unlike
some
trans women who live as gay men first
but i guess i would say i never wanted
to be a man to a woman
and i have this kind of
uh you know
i can remember sort of rep i think
there's something
inherently kind of feminine about me i
remember sort of training my voice to
sound more masculine to sound
more like to be able to be able
basically to
um not be like noticeably like
feminine as a boy um which sometimes i
i was doing more successfully than other
times um
i guess i didn't really have um
tran like i didn't sort of know what
being trans was until
my 20s i think i sort of sort of vaguely
was aware of it but it wasn't
it was it's not an attractive thing it's
what it seems like to me because you
know when you see it in media you see
like we're talking about the early 2000s
like
it's not you know it's like you know
brian
vomiting on family guy or whatever like
it's not like you don't see that on tv
and you're like oh i want to be that
like i want to be that
i want to be that like dead sex worker
in svu that's my future
like how you thought about it it's hard
to identify with that
so i don't i don't know i didn't know
what was wrong with me like i
i guess in my twenties um you know
i used to like cross-dress in bars and
like
like like i was doing like like these
these things that
i sort of didn't really have a great
explanation about why i was doing that
but the thing is so like
you you're attracted to females so when
you cross dressed into a bar you weren't
looking to pick up
guys you were just wanting to feel the
experience of being a female
yes and i guess i did like i
i guess i did sort of i don't know
people would sort of pay attention to me
as a joke i guess like men would buy me
drinks and things i would sort of enjoy
this
i uh it's hard for me to think back on
this stuff because it's like
you kind of just like i kind of just
like repress this stuff now because i
just like don't want to think about it
but i you know why you find it
embarrassing or
yeah i find it in you i find it like
shameful i guess
um and i i guess i kind of struggle with
that a lot like
um i
because it's it's cringe like yeah
it's cringe to have yourself like not
figured yourself out to such an extent
that you're like you're doing things
that
are sort of baby steps in the direction
of like what's eventually going to be
your social identity
but in this really like awkward way but
can you forgive yourself for doing that
in the in in the fact that you were kind
of just
desperately trying to figure out what
you were going to go through i mean it
doesn't seem cringy it seems like
someone who's trying to you know figure
out their identity one way or the other
who doesn't know
what's going on i think that would be
the psychologically healthy way to do it
yes
yeah yeah i don't i don't find that
embarrassing i if
if anything if i can i i think it's
incredibly brave to do that i would be
scared to do something like that
well i used to i used to i used to just
be like black out drunk when i was dead
that's that's another thing but even
still it's like to have the
courage to go do that and to try to
express yourself like that
is is scary i mean it's terrifying yeah
it was scary
uh and and it was scary to me um
i i kind of um
would it would go through these stages
of like being more
brave about it and then being a coward
like i
um i know for there was a while in my
mid-20s when i was basically like
i was presenting as this kind of like
gender [ __ ] like
i don't know i don't know how to just i
guess we call it genderqueer now
but basically i was like i was like only
shopping in the women's section for
for one year and like you know i wasn't
being perceived as a woman i wasn't
identifying as a woman i was still using
a male name
but like my nails were painted i was
wearing jewelry and like i was kind of
okay with that for a while
um but i just kind of the the like
again it's like there's this like shame
and i was like no no this is crazy like
i i was also very judgmental of other um
like gender non-conforming people i
guess that's another like
so something that's true i think for a
lot of lgbt people is that like a lot of
us go through a stage
where not only do we want to pass as
normal but we also kind of participate
ourselves
in the homophobia or the transphobia and
bigotry
like and this is not this is like
another i'm not
i'm definitely not proud of this but
like i used to i was like grossed out by
other people like me
you know what i mean and there's a sense
of like no i'm not i'm not gonna
to give in to this i wouldn't call it a
degeneracy
i i mean i wouldn't have said that
explicitly but i felt it
you know when you say people like me you
mean like people who were fully
transitioned or people who are like kind
of cross-dressing
people who are gender non-conforming and
like everybody in that broad category
i would say especially people who are
sort of assigned male but who are
presenting in like an ambiguous way
like i can remember being in chicago
where i was kind of being like
i don't i don't even know i mean at the
time i would probably just call myself
like a full-time
cross-dresser which sounds like in
retrospect i have to like
shake my head this like a full-time
crossdresser are you listening to
yourself
like but like but like but like i
remember seeing like
seeing like a trans woman on the like
the l
in chicago the train and just being like
nope like i can that's i can't handle
this i can't be that
i don't want to look like that you
thought was so like
that you hated so much what was it that
you saw i saw
um
i guess it was a person who
i saw sort of a freak basically like a
deviant abnormal
someone possibly delusional does this
person think they look like a woman well
they don't
i can tell that everyone can tell that i
don't want to be this delusional crazy
person
it was it was the issue of can you pass
as a woman for real
it's kind of holding a mirror up to
yourself and your deepest fears about if
you could actually pass
well i think yeah i think you just kind
of you just kind of nailed it because i
think that that
there's a lot of different reasons why
people cross-dress in my case it was
because of
this gender dysphoria that i didn't have
like i wasn't quite being honest with
yet
because the truth is that i wanted to
pass and i've and i've always kind of
that's always been something i kind of
cared about
and i was kind of like but i didn't
think that i could at the time
i didn't i didn't have the the skills to
um
and so when i saw other you know
either trans women or you know however
they were defined i guess probably trans
who didn't pass i kind of saw like oh
that's me like that's what i look like
that's and it's wrong i don't want to be
that um which i think is probably one
reason why like once i actually started
my medical transition i like
i did kind of prioritize being able to
pass as female because
it's you know i guess this is kind of
this is an ugly thing like i don't
endorse this at all like like
we absolutely as a society like need to
be kinder to people who are presenting
ambiguously but i guess i myself
internalized that to the point that i
was like horrified by the idea
that i would be presenting as like a man
in a dress for example
it's such a hard thing to do though
because like like i said it's it takes
so much courage to first go out into the
world
like that because you know there's so
much attention on you so many people
judging you
and then you something so painful inside
of you has to be pushing you to do that
so it's kind of like you're getting [ __ ]
internally and externally um
i always hear about people who are
dealing with gender dysphoria is gender
dysphoria like a good way to say it
because i i don't know
if trans people use that or because i've
heard people who like are against
trans who think like you shouldn't be
trans use that term
to just dismiss it as like oh it's just
a mental illness
but wow yeah
it's still kind of like a medical term
gender dysphoria which just describes
like
basically like distress
at being in some way feeling like you're
not the right
gen either you're living in the wrong
gender role your body is wrong
like uh you know it can take a lot of
different forms
um i think that uh
this is like it's an accepted notion in
the trans community that this is a thing
that exists
um there's like a lot of debate about
like oh do you need dysphoria to be
trans
uh that gets really complicated i i i
won't go into that but like
i think that for me like yeah there was
this always this like
this sense of kind of like existential
almost like
wrongness about the way i was living and
this longing i guess to
get out of it and overcome it but at the
same time it took me a long time to
understand
that that was something i could actually
do um
and i guess what eventually really
helped me was youtube and seeing other
people do it
made it more like real because it kind
of seems like magic when you don't know
how to how trans people transition
right it's interesting it's hard to
imagine doing it yourself
until you see like someone do it so
i guess the thing about gender dysphoria
that i was getting to is like i guess
people who suffer or
i don't know if you say suffer but who
have gender dysphoria tend to be
having high higher suicide rates
more depression more anxiety is that
true as far as you know that's true
right
yes it is it's true that trans people
have um
very high rates of suicide attempted
suicide depression
and i think that's mix a mix of things
like one is that uh
the condition of being trans for a lot
of people is itself quite
um you know it's complicated and painful
but a lot of it is that like the society
that we live in like really piles on top
of that
a lot of unnecessary hate and discomfort
and difficulty and shame
and that is a i think a huge
contributing factor also
i think so too because i think if you
look back at homosexual when
homosexuality was kind of
characterized as some kind of deviant
mental illness
i mean it was considered a mental
illness not that long ago yeah until the
70s yeah
and so i think if you look back you
probably see
similarly high suicide rates and
depression and anxiety
amongst them you know that's what you
would yeah
so it is a societal thing because every
society is meant
meant to make you feel like what you're
doing and what you're feeling is
is wrong and and and then well even more
than that in my opinion
is it's instilling you and you a feeling
of wanting to fight yourself which is
always kind of like the most damaging
thing one can do to themselves
yeah it's that that's and i think that
really accounts for a lot of the um
the kind of the the the depression and
shame and suicidality
is that you come to basically
be an accomplice of your owner pressure
oppressors right in terms of beating
yourself up
and that's like something that's that's
definitely been a consistent thing in my
life
so now that you've kind of how how many
years into your transition are you
medically three and a half okay um so
i've been i've been
i'm doing this full time for three and a
half years i'm curious you considered it
magic so now that i'm kind of on the
other side of
doing this medically for three years
like what kind of medicine do you take
and
how what was the process like in in the
you know onset
or well first of all was there anything
that made you decide like okay i'm just
gonna do this
well i think that i i
i started this youtube channel in 2016.
and like the persona i decided you know
what i'm just doing this
this channel in drag basically because i
had reached a point where i was like
i was like kind of like a [ __ ] moment
in my life where i was like well
like not i'm i'm 27 or 20 years old
nothing i've done so far has succeeded
like at this point why hide this part of
myself you know
like what do i have to lose basically
was the thought so
uh you know but youtube gave me a um
i mean it really did give me a way to
get more and more
like comfortable sort of feeling out my
femme self
like because i i guess initially i would
kind of play it off almost as a joke
um that's unless it's in a way you kind
of it's uh
evade sort of the worst of the danger of
it like oh this is
you know or like a part of the persona
part of the character
yeah yeah but then i i kind of realized
that like
i'm using this persona to be myself
and once i realized that
i i guess it i couldn't sort of imagine
going back again
and i
had i guess before i came out as like a
trans woman i came out as a
gender queer so that basically that
meant i was like
not a man not a woman i don't know what
i am basically i mean okay
i shouldn't say that because some people
some people who identify as genderqueer
that that they do know who they are
that's who they are they've spent years
figuring it out and they're comfortable
with that
they're comfortable existing in this
kind in this non-binary
gender space um in my case i wasn't
really comfortable with that
that was a stepping stone on the way to
figuring out that
i just wanted to transition you know um
and
and i think it also uh
helped out i kind of met a lot of trans
people through
on because like trans people could kind
of tell that i was like what's called an
egg that's a like in the term for the
trans community it means like
a trans person hasn't hatched yet like a
trans person who's like
going through a lot of the like
dysphoria or gender non-conformity
or the kinds of precursors that are
sometimes a transition but who hasn't
like yet
realized this thing about themselves um
a lot of trans people because you could
see that in me and and so i
i sort of became friends with some of
these people and i learned
about their stories i learned how they
did it um how they transitioned
and and that's kind of how i was able to
find out what to do basically
and so what did you do did you go to
like a doc like is there a special
specialty doctor that you start seeing
well what i did
initially is i started taking black
market hormones
so i started ordering um i guess it's
called the gray market
because basically you're ordering
overseas prescription
hormones um so it's just two things that
you start taking if you're
mtf male to female one is a testosterone
like an anti-androgen so it blocks the
testosterone it lower it lowers your
blood level of testosterone down to like
a biological female level um
and then the other thing you take is
estrogen which raises your estrogen
levels to a
biological female level is there is
there any danger in lowering you
like you're you're born a man i don't
know the biology but i know like
in in men adult men whose testosterone
goes super low it can cause like medical
complications do you experience stuff
like that
well it is important you have to have
some kind of sex hormones in your body
or it is dangerous
so you need either test um testosterone
or estrogen
so if you have estrogen that kind of
fixes
some of the problems that happen if you
just have very low testosterone like
um for instance like i know i don't know
it's been a while since
i learned about the specifics of this
but it's like bad for your bones to like
not have
any sex hormones or not have high enough
levels
um it's pretty like there's like some
side effects of doing
um you know testosterone blockers
especially but it's
for me it's really there's really been
no significant complications like
it changes it changes more than your
body though like it changes your moods
it changes your sex drive like it
changes all kinds of things
um gender is not just a social like
it is a social construct but the
biological sex is a real thing
and when you change your hormones it
changes a lot of stuff
with that that's really fascinating yeah
so
you're taking the the blocker
the and you're taking the estrogen
are these injections how do you take
this i just take them as a pill some
people do injection injections seem
scary especially if you're getting [ __ ]
from like
that's what i think too is that
injections i'm afraid of needles so i'm
like well i'll just do pills if you
uh yeah i didn't know you could do pills
go pets yeah yeah
and so how what did you first start
feeling like when you're
i'm really curious about you said that
you're having different moods and sexual
drives and all this i'm really curious
about the differences in the that you
started to feel
well when you lower your testosterone i
mean it does what you'd expect like it
makes they lower your sex drive
um for sure um and
it's it i would um you know a lot of
people report conflicting things some
people say
that they feel more emotional that they
cry more when you have estrogen
also you might be slower to anger i mean
it's kind of like the opposite of what
like
steroids would do where you're like
raising your testosterone and
roid rage or whatever um i guess
physically um it it sort of your skin
gets
smoother um and kind of
itch it really changes the texture of
your skin it changes the texture of your
hair especially your body hair you have
like less body hair that starts to go
away
uh you start growing breasts um
and it kind of redistributes the fat on
your body
so like whereas men tend to kind of like
accumulate more
body fat around the gut like women will
accumulate more of it like in the hips
for example so you sort of notice these
changes in the shape of your body
that's that's amazing did it were you
what did you feel when you first started
knowing this stuff
noticing this stuff did it feel like i
mean it's pretty magic
yeah it is incredible i mean it's like
it's almost kind of annoying to be
around someone who's in that early part
of transition
because it's all they want to talk about
it's definitely all i wanted to talk
about like it's
it's those first few months when you're
on hormones it's like oh my god it's
it's
it does feel like a miracle like it's
it's hard to believe that
that it's happening but um i guess i've
gotten so you
i've i've kind of gotten so used to it
now that it's like lost that sense of
magic
but definitely yeah when i started it it
seemed like magic and so now you you
have to continue to take these i'm
assuming right
yes yes so i um i i have to continue to
take
uh these basically for the rest of my
life um both of them
and until i get um with with
what we now usually just call bottom
surgery which used to be called like
having a sex change but basically if you
don't have
i mean to get really anatomical about it
like if you do not have male gonads your
body is not producing testosterone
uh so you have you don't have to take
the
testosterone blocker anymore so
is that kind of do you have that goal
for yourself to get that surgery
i do yeah and just fyi i
don't ask trans people about that i
don't care
but uh a lot of trans people don't want
to talk to talk about like what
surgeries they want to get
oh okay i don't care so don't worry
about it i apologize
that's the i guess that was my fear of
going to this conversation is that i
don't know what
well i'd rather i'd rather you not i'd
rather you
talk through this without feeling like
you can't ask questions because i feel
like
especially when you're doing a podcast
like it's valuable to educate people i
i am super interested i i have no like i
have no firsthand
account of any of this stuff and i yeah
and my my intentions are
like i uh i truly am
extremely curious and nice and super
empathetic with your
journey so i hope i'm not offending
anyone no you no you're not
nothing to me but i'm kid so so you so
your intention
if you give me permission to ask this
question is
to do you remove do you remove
everything or just the go now
so bottom surgery has gotten very
sophisticated
for male to female transitions i mean
what they can do
is they can basically create a
surgically
constructed um vagina in labia
and [ __ ] so wow um
yeah it's very it's gotten very
sophisticated i mean they've been doing
this
like i guess they first started doing
these surgeries in like the 1930s
and back then it was yeah that's when
the first one was 1930s
it was very crude back then um but you
know it's been almost 100 years that the
surgeons have been doing this now
so it's gotten very fancy like there's
there's there's versions of it now that
are done with the robots
um and you know it's uh
you know different surgeons have like
different methods but
a lot of the people's results now are
very good like you can
they're sexually functional you can have
orgasms like um
so it's it's not you know some people
think oh it's just a wound you're just
creating a hole or
like no no it's not that it's much it's
much more sophisticated than that
the results they look pretty uh natural
and
and they're they're pretty functional
so you sign yeah your intention is to do
that are what is are you what are you
waiting for i guess is my
um well basically i have
done i had on like facial surgery a year
ago
a year and a half ago and that was kind
of my my first priority because
well i'm a youtuber so you know but i
think that
that surgery was tough and it's kind of
maybe like
i need a break before i do more surgery
in what way like
just painful and it's painful difficult
and like
kind of terrifying like going into a
major surgery is scary
like the night before because this is
the first time i've had a major surgery
so the night before i was like
you know it kind of set in like oh god
like tomorrow they're gonna like
cut into my face and saw my bones down
it's like that's
like in the abstract you're like okay
let's do that but then when you think
about it happening to your skull you're
like
oh it makes you if you almost feel faint
just thinking i'm also just squeamish
like i'm a little baby about this kind
of stuff so
well and i would imagine that the the
other surgery we just talked about would
probably
be even a scarier prospect uh
yeah it's it's a major major surgery so
you know yeah
it takes like a month to to recover um
you know
people you're on your feet in a couple
weeks um but um
yeah and the other thing is the wait
lists for these things can actually be
quite long
so oh the waitlist really yeah yeah so a
lot of research
there's probably not a lot of doctors
that specialize in that is that the
issue
yeah it's a very specialty thing i mean
it used to be the case that a lot of
girls would go to thailand to get it
done because there are these
oh it's common there there's a lot of
yeah yeah yeah yeah there's a kind of um
i guess a culture of of sort of trans
women there
and a lot of doctors who cater to it and
so some of the you know for a long time
like
the thai surgeons were actually the best
um so you would go there to get it was
doctor sue porn was his name was there's
just one guy doing it
yeah there's one guy doing it just
hundreds or thousands of trans women
have been through this one guy um but
a lot of american surgeons have have
gotten quite good in the last
decade so what what kind of surgery did
you have in your face if i can ask that
i'm kind of curious
this was an issue you to help because we
talked briefly about like
your wanting to pass as a female was
this basically
to make you look more female the facial
surgery
yes so
facial surgery is like it's a con it's
kind of a controversial thing right
and that's true even if you're not trans
like if you have
suppose you're a woman and you have like
a very angular nose and you get a
rhinoplasty
to make it more like straight or
there's definitely people who have
negative feelings about that because
there's people who say like oh well
you're just trying to replicate this
like eurocentric beauty standard
like and you know this kind of thing
right so there's definitely like a
transversion of this where people say
like
no like the goal of being trans should
not be to look the same as
a cis woman um but
you know it's ultimately i think it's a
personal choice
right some um it's
for me that there's a lot of reasons why
i wanted to to have
the facial i can tell you i can tell you
exactly what they did
they kind of um sort of shaved down my
brow bone
so that uh if you look at like
a lot of like people in profile you'll
notice that on average
men tend to have a more prominent like
stronger brow
um and they also
kind of narrowed my jaw a little bit i
used to have like a more kind of square
chin it's now pointy um they
did what's called a trachea shave where
basically you
it's like a little i have a little scar
here where they like basically like
um make your adam's apple smaller so it
looks more like a
a cis woman's throat um and
uh so that's what i did and
basically it's it's kind it makes it
sort of easier for me to
read to people as female so i used to
feel like when i left the house i felt
like i couldn't leave the house without
a full face of makeup
you know like because i was so anxious
about like oh god how are people going
to perceive me are they going to see me
as a woman am i going to get clocked am
i going to get yelled at if i go to the
bathroom you know
there's all these kinds of anxieties
that you have about you know
it's not just vanity like some people
think maybe there's a little bit of
vanity but like
there's it's not just vanity right like
like it's like a lot of trans people
have safety concerns and if you're able
to be
less detectable like it's it can make
your life
you feel more yourself beside that yeah
just you feel like more yourself i
totally understand that
yeah and then there's and also that of
course yeah so yeah to me
to me this was something that i'm very
happy i did it i have no regrets
um you had all that done in one session
and one second that sounds absolutely
brutal
it's terrible oh my goodness was your
face all bandaged and everything
was yeah like full head of bandages
exactly
god and like how do you even file down
the forehead because like
you must have had a huge i don't know
how they do that well
i don't want to get too like gross out
about it but they basically
i mean surgery is it's amazing like what
they can do basically they
they do an incision behind your head oh
and they go
under they kind of peel your forehead
down
it's like it's it's scary but like
they're they're good at it
and so like basically i used to have a
like um you know there was kind of like
a almost like a bald spot here where
the incision was across the top of my
head that's gone now because the hair
was grown over it so you can't even
notice that
there's no scars it's very it's like the
result is very like you can't tell that
surgery happened
wow that yeah that's that sounds well
all that at one time how long did it
take you to recover
um i would say it was about 10 days of
recovery
and then the swelling that lasted
another month right
like uh but uh yeah it's
it's it's it's not as bad as you might
think although
it's the first three days that are
really horrible
so now that you're kind of on the other
side of uh
not entirely i guess there's still more
to go but like you've come a long way
right from from those first days
so how are you feeling now about being a
female and and
like you talk about you're depressed
before and all this like
has it helped a lot of the do you feel
better
like just yeah i would say that it's
it's helped
exactly one area of my life it's helped
the gender problem that was kind of a
defining thing for
for my whole adult life up until this um
it really has helped
but i won't say i'm not going to say
that oh it solves all your problems like
no it doesn't solve all your problems
like if if anyone's going into
transition because it's going to solve
all your problems or give you a new
identity
it doesn't do that it doesn't do that at
all in fact it adds a lot of new
problems
in a lot of ways um you know i guess i'm
in a weird situation because
i've kind of transitioned very much i
mean on youtube basically
so it's been very much in the public eye
um
and so with that comes a lot of scrutiny
a lot of judgment a lot of
responsibility when it comes to
other trans people see you like not just
as an individual person
but like they see you as doing the work
of kind of representing them to the
public
and so if you do something they don't
like if you say something they don't
like
and they feel you're kind of you're kind
of [ __ ] them because you're
misrepresenting them
so that's a tough situation to be in
because it's like
you know i can't just be myself um
and you know i i kind of i kind of found
a way to
find a new like closet to get into
when i transitioned because when i did
once i transitioned
i started dating men because
i i sort of i don't know there there's
this anxiety
that i had about like you know oh i have
to show the world that i'm
really a woman and like that means
trying to be like
it's almost you almost like you leave
like one gender prison and you kind of
move into a different one that's
what happened to me anyway where now i'm
kind of like
i feel this obligation to be like a
gender conforming woman in every respect
which included dating men so i did that
for for a couple years
before realizing like um i mean
actually like the people i'm usually
attracted to are
are the other trans women um it's a form
of it's a form of gayness that straight
people haven't even found out about
yet so so you're not attracted to like
uh
sit like cis females you're you're
mostly attracted to
trans females like yourself well i'm
actually i'm actually trying to say i'm
attracted to both
but i just i'm mostly interested in
dating trans women
because uh i don't know this might
change later in my life but at the
moment there's
kind of a lot of reasons why i find it
just easier to date trans women like
we have this kind of shared
understanding
of this like background and this journey
uh like there's a lot of stuff that you
have to explain
to a partner who isn't trans that you
kind of just don't
with someone who's trans so to me i i
don't know i like
i like being with trans women because i
just
i just find it sort of very relaxing i
guess in a way that
i would sort of yeah and there's also a
kind of like
i don't know and in some ways i would
always worry if i was
with um if i was with a cis woman i'd i
was kind of worried that
about being like oh like the more like
male part i mean i know that's like not
like a healthy worry but like
it's it's it's just like a subtle
psychological thing that it's like
uh it's it's kind of nice to to to not
worry about that
to not worry that about the difference
between my body and the body of my
partner
so when you first transition you you
felt compelled to date
men just because you like
it's just it goes to show how
complicated it can be there's all these
things
and especially the social pressure
because i think a lot of people would
say oh okay so you're trans
female but you're attracted to female
they might be like
you know that that sounds ridiculous
like wow
yeah i think a lot of people think that
is ridiculous um
i think that in that sense that it's
ridiculous i think
probably caused me to not transition
sooner in some ways
because it's it's it does seem like
i guess it seems to people like the
point of transitioning is to be
attractive to men
but it's not like uh you know if
if you're if you want to attract men and
you're born male
uh there's a lot of men who are into men
and
you can attract them so people who
transition
it's it's not just about who you want to
attract it's
like rarely really about who you want to
attract it's about like who you are
like how you want to experience the
world and like like
who you are as a person what kind of
body do you feel at home and what kind
of
um you know social world you have to
perform although i just say
social world's sort of different from
gender it's not i'm not talking about
gender stereotypes
because obviously like i'm not a
stereotypical woman in a lot of ways
um stereotypical women don't date women
for instance right right
um but yeah i think i think to me
it wasn't just the shame of it that led
me to date men i sort of
uh i guess there was i made a whole
video about this called shame
on my channel where i talk about like my
experience dating men and
and like other things i genuinely liked
about it like
i i think i'm someone who has like
a sexuality that's at least a little bit
fluid to the point where
uh like i don't know i guess i call
myself like a gay trans woman a trans
one who's attracted to women
but i would say that like i'm not the
most like
the most um i'm not the least bisexual
person
i guess you can put it that way like
like i haven't enjoyed
like sexual experiences men even enjoy
dating men
um it's just that i feel like that's
kind of like not
really the right um i'm trying to think
of people are gonna be mad at me because
i'm like misrepresenting lesbianism or
something but
um i just wish i could identify as
nothing sometimes so i could just not
represent anybody
it's so complicated your life is so
complicated i mean it's like yeah
you're cl this is the part that's that's
so challenging for me and
like someone who's just honestly trying
to understand it and i can only imagine
in your in your case it's like you're
someone who's honestly trying to
you know convey who they are and how
they feel and yet there's the people are
can be so judgmental
maybe it's just because the position
you're in is so sensitive so i don't i
don't want to judge them for being
judgmental
but like i know that people have gotten
mad at you for things that you've said
about
being trans and it's like you know you
like you said you're escaping one cage
you're entering another one i just
it makes it hard to have conversations
when we're all on eggshells i feel like
and i don't know if you agree or maybe
i'm just being overly
yeah no maybe it's easier for me to say
yes i'm on the outside looking at you
know
um i think to some extent that's true it
is very very difficult to talk about
these things in public in this day and
age
um in and you're right there's a lot of
judgment coming from a lot of directions
like there's a lot of people who would
want to tell there's a lot of people who
are very confident that they know who
and what i am
despite the fact that they've thought
about this for 10 seconds and i've
thought about this for 20 years
right you know what i mean like a lot of
people say well well if
you're transplanting well you're just
you're just a gay man and deny on and
then i say well i'm going to charge a
woman and so they say well you're just a
straight man in denial
and it's like well but i'm not though
like it's it's it's
why would you go through everything
you've done yeah
if you're just a man in denial that's
just silly like i don't know why people
have
such a hard time i think people just
haven't thought it through that well
like and it's it's it's i guess when you
hear about it in the abstract
it's kind of hard to like it's hard to
imagine like
like i think you hear oh some people
have surgery to change their gender and
you think what
like having surgeries doesn't make you a
different gender
like you know like which is true
actually it's
having surgeries doesn't make you a
different gender um
to understand like where trans people
are coming from like
this is this it's um you know you don't
want to
i hate to say like corny things like
it's about your soul
but it kind of is at the end of the day
like it's about
how you experience the world
how you experience your body how you
experience relationships with other
people
it's not easy to translate that into
some simple explanation
right of like oh here's what being trans
is just
just accept it i guess my hope is that i
kind of describe my experiences to
people
and they will kind of they'll be
they'll they'll find something that
they'll be able to empathize with with
what i've experienced and and hopefully
understand it a little better
um because yeah i hope that that makes
them sort of less eager to tell them
like oh no i'm they've got me figured
out they know what i really am right
although it is possible through people
like you talking so openly about it
that something so complicated and hard
to put into words can just become maybe
um some shared common knowledge i think
maybe
i hope and like you know i don't know
how long it takes but you say when you
say
i'm a trans lesbian or however you refer
yourself people
actually know what that means and don't
try to say tell you who you are
well i agree that's my also my hope and
i think that youtube is kind of
fabulous for that kind of thing exactly
because
it well there's a lot of talk about
parasocial relationships
between creators and their fans which
means like when your people are fans of
a youtuber
well you kind of feel like you know them
on some level like i mean i've
experienced as much
of myself as a viewer of youtube like a
creator if i watch a lot of someone's
videos
i kind of it's because it's almost
delusion that they're your friend you
know
you feel like you know them because you
know so much about them um
and obviously that can lead to these
problems where people feel
like like entitled to tell you what to
do with your life because they feel like
you know your friends or whatever but
the positive side of it as i see it is
you know most people like you said like
probably
don't know a trans person they don't
they're not friends with a trans person
but if they follow your youtube channel
they watch your videos for
you know 20 hours or whatever over that
time like people
sort of that parasocial thing actually
kind of can work because it helps people
better understand the experiences
that they might never have access to
otherwise right yeah
especially so like intimately as you can
with such detail
as you can talk about it on youtube
right and that
i think gives people kind of portal into
our world that i hope
leads people to be a little bit more
understanding i think you have done
an incredible
momentous job of normalizing being trans
i mean you have this huge
presence on youtube you're extremely
popular you talk about all these broad i
mean
i have a hard time thinking of many
other people have done so much
good for normalizing what what it means
to be trans as you have
well i hope um yeah i guess i tend not
to think about it because it's like
well maybe you understand because you're
also like an influencer like
if you think about your influence it's
hard to function yeah what i mean like
like when if you make a video and you
know that like okay a million people are
gonna watch this video
well a million people that's like like
madison square garden seats what 20 000
if it's full so that's like five
consecutive madison square gardens like
do i have anything that i feel
comfortable saying to that crowd like
oh god no right if you can't think about
it or you'll go crazy
but uh yeah i know i guess i feel some i
do i do hope that i've
you know used use my
my podium base here like to for
something good and
i do have to remind myself sometimes
that it doesn't it does matter it's not
just it does
it really does i i from my point of view
i i think you know
it does but but again you can't think
about your influence you're totally
right
for me i i always ignore it but maybe
it's just me trying to pay you a
compliment or something i don't know
well i'll take the compliment thank you
when you when
this maybe is in the weeds but i'm i
know that there's like
do you feel like trans people are
sometimes fetishized and like
pornography or popular media and then
when you're in the dating world let's
say you're dating guys
do you ever wonder like is this guy into
me as a person
or is he like fetishizing me is that a
thought that comes to your mind is that
a problem in the trans
world yeah this is a major issue i would
say um i think
you know a lot of men probably first
really encountered the concept of a
trans woman
in porn like because it's it's a very
popular category
it comes up you know like and a lot of
times
that's not the greatest introduction
because
it does present trans women in a very
like fetishized way
right and that can even like go into
uh like the language that's used like
i'm going to say bad words now so
twitter just ignore this part but like
you know
it's like it's the categories like
[ __ ] porn she-male porn right
which i think cause i think like if this
is how you go around the world thinking
about trans women
females [ __ ] like it's kind of it's
like it's a little bit of a dehumanizing
perspective and a lot of trans women
will be irritated
uh well more than irritated like like
you know if
they get the sense that you just want to
date them out of some experiment of oh
i'm curious to be
uh with a chick with a dick right like
that's not
um you know what is a trans woman going
to get out of that she's what just
giving you an experience like no because
trans women want what everyone else
wants
we want to be valued for ourselves we
want to be loved we want to be
uh you know we want to have
relationships we don't just want to be
someone's like
exotic sex tourism for a night
[Music]
the fact that it's so popular on in porn
sites
what do you think about that like is
that good is that bad like what does
that mean that that it's
turned into this this porn category
uh it means a lot of men are liars it
means
well they're not liars i shouldn't
that's too judgmental but i would say
there's a lot more men who are attracted
to trans women and trans women's bodies
than are
publicly open about that fact um i would
say that
you know we talk about the shame of
being trans there's also some
there's also shame attached to being
attracted to trans people um
and a lot of people find themselves
attracted to trans people and then they
don't kind of know
what to make of that because in their
heads like oh
like suppose you're a man and you're
think of yourself
and you're heterosexual and you know but
you find yourself
attracted to this woman who has a penis
and then for a lot of men that causes
them to have this kind of crisis where
they're like oh god is this gay i'm like
okay who am i what is anything like
like uh i guess i encourage people to
like
relax a little a little bit like the the
fact of the matter is that like
sexuality is very complicated
most of us are a little more fluid than
we like to think
and also i would say that you know if
you're worried
is it is it gay the quote well no it's
not gay is the short answer i would say
because
what it means to be a gay man is to be a
man who's attracted to men
because you were attracted to a woman
with a penis does that mean now suddenly
you want to have sex with men like no it
doesn't mean that it means that you're
attracted to
a woman and that woman had a penis like
you're answering the time old question
of the internet here today oh yes well i
have a video
on the subject called r traps gay oh oh
you do i haven't seen that our trap i
don't know
and i i don't know the answer is no uh
the answer is the short answer is no
yeah the video is an hour long if you
want the long answer
and i made that video i made that video
when i was you know
dating men so i it was something that
was kind of on my mind and i had had
these
experiences did these men who were
dating you ever have these kind of
conflicts of identity
of identity like am i gay am i straight
what's going on
um yes
i i definitely have had have had men um
it sends them into this like deep
philosophical
spiral uh sometimes or i've also had
like
i don't know you have a lot of
experiences that are interesting like i
don't know i had um
like some men will think like oh i'm
attracted to you but like
i don't i'm not attracted to penises so
i'm not
interacting with that at all and and i
and a couple of times i said okay to
that because
i don't know i guess i have no
self-respect whatever but like i
uh i don't know but but then they would
kind of get interested as they became
interested in me
but people like there's a kind of
complicated thing about sexual
attraction where
people think that like sexual attraction
is to
body parts right so what it means to be
uh
you know what it means to be attracted
to women is oh i love vaginas right or
something like that
well and what i mean and what it means
to be intimate i love dick
okay a lot of times that's probably true
but sometimes um you know sexual
attraction is not so
like atomistic it's not so like zoomed
in on one little
fetishized body part and like if you're
a
i think people often are surprised when
they first find themselves attracted to
a trans person because
um you know you always think like penis
man
vagina woman well most people have not
really encountered the body of someone
who has like
breasts for example and a penis and i
guess
um you know
initially i guess that's just make make
people uncomfortable
because they don't their sort of brain
doesn't know how to process this
right including the part of their brain
that is involved in sexual attraction
like uh like well maybe i'm attracted to
parts of this person but other parts i
don't know and like
and then and then like so i think this
is where some of the the
this is where the deep philosophical
introspection comes in right
as people try to understand what it
means that they're attracted
to something that they didn't think that
they would be attracted to
i wonder what it says about us that it's
just it's such a big deal anyway
it's like okay this person has a penis
and you find yours that you're
that you're attracted to this person
which includes their penis
like why does that have to be an it like
such a ground
like why do what does it keep you know
what i mean it's like okay who cares
like what's the big [ __ ]
interest when you break it down like
that it's kind of crazy right that
people like like
like who cares exactly like it really
doesn't matter and it shouldn't be such
a big deal
i guess what the reason it seems to
matter to people is that people get
yeah and people get very invested in
their identity
and their identity includes like a
sexuality if you go through life
thinking
that you're a straight man like
to have something that that maybe makes
you um
sort of that sort of shakes your
certainty on that can be
it's not just about like oh i was
attracted to this person one it's like
who am i right that's why that's why it
does that yeah but i wonder if it also
underlies some some notion that we as
society society still hold be like
gay bad or trans bad and so it's like oh
no i like
there's something bad about me now that
i like this person which includes their
penis
yeah i think that um yeah i think that
there's definitely
there's definitely still stigma on
homosexuality like and that's especially
true i think if you're like
a masculine man who is in you know
operating in heterosexual spaces like
there's there's real stigma
to to you know even like being a
bisexual man like
i've heard from from by men who i know
that like there's a women who will just
like a lot of women actually who will
just
straight up refuse to date them simply
because they've been with guys or
because they have some attraction to men
also
so i think that for a lot of people
there's sort of
there's there's social pressure and
there's sort of an incentive
to be more black and white rather than
shades of gray
when the reality often is more shades of
gray right
so let me ask you this then because you
you seems like you're dating
life so far has been a lot about like
you're a female but you also have a
penis so
what happens when you get the surgery
and you
like fully transition to female how does
that affect your dating life do you
think
well i think that um you know
some trans women i know find that it
actually leads to a decrease in people
who are interested
because so many of the people who are
interested are interested in this
like i said was talking about this like
exotic chick with a dick experience
well most trans women don't particularly
mind that drop off and partners
because they're not really interested in
being this fetish object
right so for some trans women i think it
comes as like a liberation like it's
like well
now at least i know that anyone who's
interested in me is interested in me for
the right reasons
um and i think that
um you know
[Music]
it's it's valid for people to have
different attractions like i understand
that like
there's there's going to be people who
only want like who who
are willing to be with a trans woman but
only if she has a vagina
um right only if she's post-op um so you
know
that kind of changes if if you you can
date those people after you post up
obviously
and then there's people who people who
are only after this like girl with a
penis experience
then they won't want to date you anymore
so uh
you know that's something that trans
people consider but i think for the most
part
like this is not really like why we're
having the surgery or not
it's it's about us you know it's about
our bodies and what we want and how
we've
you know how what we have to do to feel
comfortable it's not about like oh i'm
doing this
to make other people attracted to me so
uh there's so much to think about i mean
it's it's
it's a lot for for
for you guys going through that it is a
lot yeah it takes up a lot of life
just figuring it all out well what is it
like
um you're a progressive is that the
right title i think probably
i i like that title yeah yeah you're
progressive you're trans
on a platform where conservative
politics seems to be like the
predominant force and so i'm just
curious what's your experience like on
youtube
uh are people do you find a lot of
hostile forces do you find a lot of
supportive forces i mean
both i'm sure but kind of curious on
your experience
well when i started it was 2016 and back
then it was even more true
that it was a conservative platform like
i guess
uh this was the era of sjw cringe
compilations
purple-haired feminists 76 genders like
this whole moment in youtube internet
history
um yeah i guess that that kind of stuff
was kind of initially
kind of what motivated me to start
making youtube videos
is that i saw that there was this kind
of political commentary on
on community not necessarily a community
but like a market i guess
for this kind of content getting just
doing huge numbers millions of views
about people dunking on like 17 year old
like
feminists or whatever um i was just like
okay
there's like an opening here for someone
to come in and like
walk the shot uh block the shot exactly
yeah
so i i guess that's kind of what i what
i
sort of set out to do at the beginning
is like um
you know i wanted to kind of introduce a
more
nuanced discussion of this and like i
guess i i had been
you know in academia a graduate grad
student so
i had been around the campus activists
like
i knew how annoying they could be and so
i guess on some level
i i understood like i could have like a
visceral
sympathy with the people who are
anti-social justice warrior
because it's like yeah a lot of social
justice warrior behavior
is very annoying and very off-putting
and i get why people don't like it
but i i guess what i saw was that in
response
to this like annoying preachy uh
you know kind of behavior was that
people were just like
shutting down any interest in
progressive causes and things were going
like speeding into the right wing very
fast and
you know it it was something i was sort
of personally invested in because a lot
of this was
you know the trans people were kind of
scapegoated through a lot of this as
like
these crazy snowflakes and you know i
kind of
knew that i was part of that group so
i there was always kind of this this
incentive i guess
personal uh involvement where i kind of
wanted to
make myself understood by more people
than just
the people who were already like vocal
activists you know
i wanted to be understood but better by
normal people
by like a general youtube audience like
i don't know if that's normal but
but you know that that's sort of what i
uh envisioned for the beginning so you
know as things have grown
like there is a big leftist community on
youtube now
i mean i've got like one like a million
subscribers more than a million
subscribers now so
a lot of the feedback i see is now very
positive
but when i started that was definitely
not the case like i got like the first
few videos i think i uploaded on this
channel
got mostly downvoted oh really yeah is
that discouraging did you ever feel like
quitting
um actually no because
i felt like to to me
i saw it as a challenge to
find out how to how to get these people
you know what i mean how to get these
people on my side like
and so i guess even though i was being
attacked i was like all right
like what can you know i don't know i've
always kind of wanted to be an
entertainer
right like i mentioned my past as a
musician
on youtube i want to be an entertainer
too and part of that
part of being an entertainer is winning
over an audience right
like you have to kind of get people
not just speak to people but also get
them to want to listen
and so i found you know by trying to
make my videos more entertaining
uh and by using kind of theatrics and
other things like that
i could sort of make a video that was
very inviting um
so sort of easy easier to get into and
you know uh not not so like here's what
you believe
here's the list of the 10 things that
are bigoted about what you're doing you
know what i mean like
like that i didn't want to do that kind
of content because it seems like it just
drove people away
interesting i mean what do you what do
you think about
there's people like let's say
do you think youtube's a good place to
to engage with i mean you have
these huge like tim poop and shapiro
the quartering who pees in his own
basement i don't know if you know about
that
oh you don't okay that's fine but um
you i i don't know what it is they have
like these daily shows right
that they they command these huge
audiences but
what really interested me is when you
made this jordan peterson video
who is like you know this godfather of
kind of conservatism
in a way and if you go over to like the
jordan peterson subreddit you can see
that the people there are really
reasonable or like they're actually
really receptive to your video i thought
that was really interesting
yeah i got interested in jordan peterson
well initially i got interested in
jordan peterson because
he kind of rose to fame as someone who
was speaking out against the pronoun
thing yeah
and for what so i kind of resented him
at first because
everyone was asking me all the time why
are you taking away our free speech why
are you trying to send people to jail
for using the wrong pronoun well of
course we're not trying to do that no
one has ever gone to jail for using the
wrong pronoun
in canada so it was all fear-mongering
but
i guess i i i decided i don't know
why don't i start listening to this
guy's podcast so
i started listening to jordan peterson's
podcast and i actually thought
that it was very interesting um like i
don't know i just i just found him like
an
interesting person and i sort of
i guess i felt like i was sort of
getting why a lot of people liked him
right um and that he well he's he's
and i i can see to a certain kind of
person he's like it could be a dazzling
speaker he's
educated very educated and he has all
these examples and he
uh seems to be offering like life advice
as well as
politics and a lot of the life advice is
kind of
you know self-help motivational stuff so
it's the combination of that with like
his attacking
the uh you know the sort of
activism that irritates a lot of people
so
this was a recipe for success um but i
guess
i fundamentally disagreed with a lot of
what he was saying
about well certainly about the pronoun
thing but also
about um he was
he was kind of very alarmist about what
his phrase was like post-modern
neo-marxism
which is what he that means yeah no one
knows what it means well he said
we had him on our show a few times and
he always he would say all the time
cultural marxism and i still don't know
what
i don't know what that means i just gl
it just glazes over me
well when you ask like when you look at
the examples that he uses of like
post-modern neo-marxism or cultural
marxism it's all kind of
the same thing like he's talking about
like this
strange like imaginary union of like
hr departments that like have like
diversity quotas and hiring
plus you know leftist academics plus
um it just seems to be like all the
basically some like
conglomerate of all the institutional
forces that have anything progressive
about about them
um and you know i guess it's like a tip
it goes along with a lot of like
anti-like affirmative action arguments
as you argue that this is some kind this
is the new racism right this is into
some kind of authoritarian project
that's gonna like
uh i don't know throw you in pronoun
jail and and make you go to diversity
training or whatever um i guess my
confusion was like his alarm about that
never really amounted to anything i saw
in reality so i was always like
he's talking about like some some force
is coming to
sweep us all away the new fascism and i
the disconnect for me was just like i
had a hard time
taking that seriously because it just
didn't see anything like that in the
world that i was living in
yeah he compared um like trans activists
to stalin because he's you know he said
that others say there's the same
authoritarian principle and it's like
well first of all wanting people to call
you by
your pronouns is like very much not the
same
as like wanting to take control of a
state where you like
dictate the economy and like i mean like
it's just like not
stalinism it's it's this is like a
ridiculous exaggeration right
and also it's especially ridiculous
because
trans activists like at the end of the
day don't really have
any power um like uh
i guess you know people look at these
little cases of like oh like someone got
fired for saying something transphobic
you know what i mean and they're like
well this is it
1984 is an orwell's nightmare like but
it's like
that that's just not that's not what
authoritarianism is like that's not
that is not like having like it's just a
fringe group looking for some
acknowledgement
i didn't yeah i mean so like the thing
about the law that he became
famous for the pronoun thing i've had
trouble getting the whole thing straight
but from what i understand there was
never really
an was there ever an intention in canada
to hold people criminally liable for
using the wrong pronoun well like what
originally was the law
no i mean all that law does is bill c-16
i think is what was called
is all it does is adds transgender
people to the list of people who are
protected under like canadian human
rights oh um
like a hate crime yeah so basically that
like
yeah jews people minorities yeah
yeah and indigenous canadians right and
like the
the the argument that jordan peterson
made was like oh this could
be used to like force people to use
a certain pronoun or something you know
is this fair that anyone can say they're
trans
hey that wasn't what he that wasn't what
it was about it was about just like
fear that like oh we're going to be
coerced into using people's problems
it's going to be justified with this law
which they're going to say
right but it's total speculation that
amounted to nothing
yeah it was kind of amazing how much
built off that one story
well he's back what do you think about
he's back he's been on quite a journey
it sounds like you're somewhat of a fan
of his or at least you followed his
career
i did i wouldn't say that i'm a fan but
i did more of an anti-fan but yeah yeah
i thought his career not a fan well you
say you listen to this podcast
and you know you like what i like for
you know when i when i had them on
we didn't talk about politics we talked
about philosophy and kind of the
self-help stuff and it was great
but um but he's back he had a tough time
man i don't know if you've been
following him yeah
the benzo addiction that's a very
difficult thing
benzo meat diet and meat
that i i cannot make heads or tails of
the meat diet that seems like madness to
me
that's all meat diet apparently he's
still on it i mean i think the very fact
of what he went through may
negate all the benefits they may be
saying about the meat diet
how does he poop how do you poop if you
only eat meat
i do wonder what is i you must be like
super constipated
i would think thank you zach
like i don't know i feel like a fiber
can someone look that up
what's the bowel movements of all meat
diet look like i mean i don't want to
see a picture i'm just curious about the
description of it
bring it up yeah yeah
what are your thoughts on someone like
joe rogan i'm just kind of curious like
he he's very
popular obviously on youtube he's
leaving youtube but
he has such a huge influence on young
men yeah i think that that
that he is kind of like the biggest of
these kind of youtube voices it's
basically taught me his talk radio for
millennials right like it's it's the
sort of position that like rush
limbaugh had you know joe rogan is not
rush limba i think that his
way positions himself as more of a
um he's more of a like guide to
the various guests like he's a little
bit more neutral but i guess the problem
i
i
an objection i have with jojo rogan is
that he'll have these like very
right-wing people on
um you know especially it's actually
especially awful with the trans issue
like
he'll just have ben shapiro on to just
like talk about
why trans people are delusional perverts
or whatever
and it's like he doesn't really
challenge that very hard right
and so in effect it's like endorsing
that message to his audience
yeah that's a challenge i mean yeah as a
as a host like him it's really
challenging it's like do you not have
these people on or does he has
an obligation to be more prepared for
the arguments they're going to come up
so that he doesn't put that out as an
endorsement
yeah it's um well
it's this is this difficult decision
right like like who do you have on as a
guest like on your show
and like i to to me i don't know i don't
i don't have any principled objection
to like having ben shapiro on as like a
podcast guest
but i feel that people who have
have a responsibility i guess i don't
know like
like i feel if i were if i had a show
that i
had guests on and i had to guest on who
was saying like a bunch of racist things
like i would feel like i had some
responsibility to be like
uh whoa like i don't agree with that
that seems kind of racist you know
you know what i mean like like early
like maybe not say that but like at
least like
challenge them on it whereas if i just
let them
go and i'm like that's an interesting
opinion you know what i mean
it kind of legitimizes and normalizes
what they're saying
which is not amazing
um that said do i think it's like evil
like no i don't use evil but i think
that it's like
kind of an irresponsible use of at least
it's frustrating to me as a trans person
yeah just
to like because it's just too easy to
imagine when you say oh god like
you know 10 million people are watching
this like it's just making the world
harder for trans people it's like it's
like setting us back
it's making it's like steepening the
slope that we have to climb to get
anything
done you know or just to live our lives
even so
when you when you're whipping up
antipathy to like an already
marginalized community on your show
it just makes lives the lives of of you
know people who are out here harder
and it's hard not to have like some
negative feelings about that
yeah yeah that's understandable for sure
um guys do we have any updates on yeah
and funny enough uh since we're on the
topic of joe rogan i guess
uh i found an article where he had tried
it and reported on
uh and it's actually the opposite what i
thought um apparently it gave him
explosive diarrhea gross uh
which he described like unlike anything
he had ever experienced before not good
and said it was only a matter of time
until he shuts his pants
doesn't that mean he's not digesting his
food yeah i mean that doesn't sound very
healthy
so like no nutritionist like would ever
recommend that you only eat meat like i
don't understand
how this is seriously something that
people are entertaining
so okay so jordan apparently he started
his his daughter was like you've got to
try this all meat time yeah it's
everything
and at first he's like okay i like meat
and veggies but then he cut out the
veggies and he's like it's cured my
depression
i've lost 50 pounds but you know
he went to get like treated in russia
for a day i mean like
something went wrong with the diet it
just sounds like snake oil to me like it
sounds like a miracle for sure
like [ __ ] diet for sure i mean all
meat diet like
what is the is there like a theory
behind it dan that it's like some
like that because usually with these
diets it's like we're living like
cavemen used to live how our bodies
meant to be
but i don't see it right there at least
some logic to that um yeah i don't
i i don't i i've never really understood
what the argument for it
is i don't think we ever just got down
with me
and they robbed me too dude like raw me
that's i feel like humans invented
cooking
for a reason right and like like i don't
know
civilization has thrived with the humans
cooking it seems strange to give that up
also we have like molars like teeth in
the back for
plants yeah that are probably there for
reason
like i don't know we're not carnivores
like like cats are carnivores right like
they can only digest
meat but that's like humans are not that
so it's i feel like people always have
to take everything to
to the extreme it's like we've done
everything else now
let's just eat meat like all these diet
fats are like this is all that's left
let's just do
big massive dumps
because it's also like like jordan
peterson is someone who's so like so
like
his arguments often come from like
evolutionary biology like the whole
lobster thing it's like well there's a
hierarchies of among lobsters like we
should have the hierarchies too
like well but then but primitive humans
didn't
only eat meat so why should like it just
i don't know
it doesn't make any sense it just it
doesn't add up to me yeah
well there you go i think people these
guys these people who do these crazy
diets they're just like trying these
extreme things and
i think people kind of like people this
one's i think we see humans like
naturally we want to regulate our diet
in some way like most cultures have some
kind of dietary
code and then people who don't have one
like make them up
like keto or vegan or like i don't know
people
like the rituals the ritual yeah of
having some kind of like
i wish i had a ritual yeah i could use a
little bit of structure in my life it's
total chaos over here
yeah um it's like it's like order out of
chaos but
that seems like the wrong that seems
like an approach that
like all me i don't think that
just imagine jordan peterson having
explosive diarrhea if he would please
they call them dumps i'm picturing it
it's crystal clear
like like just not even fully digested
meat
just blasting out of his ass just animal
blood
it's just god well on that note natalie
i think we've said it all
yeah that's i don't i don't know the
universe has come to its conclusion
yeah jordan i thank you
first of all contra points on youtube
was amazing
we're all fans and i thank you for
talking so openly with me i feel like i
learned a lot and i really appreciated
our conversation and
just thanks for everything you do and
really appreciate it
very welcome thank you so much for
having me on
[Music]
[Music]